what is success
is that what you accomplished or how
much you feel you have grown learned and
your ability to change your habits
moving forward most traditional views of
success would argue that it's the former
that it's about money status recognition
and it's associated with the fleeting
feeling of happiness to experience want
to achieve a goal however another
measure of success is based on the
behaviors you take once you achieve the
goal the goal supporting activities that
enable you to make progress in important
domains of your life such as health
relationships or education now this
insight is critical because it moves us
from focusing on our achievements to
thinking about what happens after the
goal has been achieved it allows us to
move from the short-run win associated
with attaining a goal to the longer-term
benefits associated with continued
improvement after the goal has been
achieved the whole point of education is
not getting a diploma it is to acquire
the skills to keep learning in the
future and the whole point of getting in
shape is not to lose five pounds it is
to keep the weight off and maintain your
healthy habits in the future in this
light success isn't the short run when
it's the subsequent activity that you
adopt after you achieved your goal in
our research we focus on how to achieve
this type of longer term success we have
pathi sized that instead of focusing
only on the goal has been attained
individuals will be better served by
reflecting on all the steps it took to
achieve it and to think metaphorically
about the entire effort as a journey
rather than a destination so we
recruited more than 1,600 dieters
exercisers business executives and
university students to think about their
goals success as a journey they just
completed or a destination they just
reached for example we designed a 14-day
walking program and asked volunteers to
download a pacer mobile app to track
their steps the participants would state
they're walking goal and tracked how far
they walked after reaching their goal
they were then given the opportunity to
continue tracking their steps for 3 more
days we found that the exercisers who
were guided to think about completing
the probe
as a journey what close to 5500 more
steps during the three additional days
that's a 55% increase in steps taken in
another study we work with stem proceed
executive education program in the
African country of Ghana we give one
cohort of executives a journey for
practice during the graduation ceremony
they were asked to think about what they
achieved as a journey another cohort was
instructed to think about their
graduation as a destination we also had
a control cohort who wasn't asked to
reflect at all during their graduation
ceremony the stem froz program then
tracked these executives business
practices for six months after
graduation the executives who used the
journey metaphor to think about their
achievements were more likely to put
their learning into practice when
leading their companies after they left
the program what's important here is
that when you look back at your past
achievements as a journey instead of a
destination reached that mindset helps
you to recognize and learn from the ups
and downs along the path inducing a
feeling of growth and fueling positive
behaviors moving forward but this
doesn't mean that the destination
mindset is without value it can be
beneficial during the actual pursuit of
a goal when you are in the middle of
pursuing a goal it is important to have
a North Star or destination in mind it
helps you sharpen focus and work harder
however when you achieve the goal this
research shows it helps to shift
mindsets and take a moment to think
about what you have accomplished as a
journey in this light
success isn't the short run win it's the
behavior that you adopt after you
achieved your goal and a dirty mindset
helps you stay focus on that type of
success so real success comes down to
anchoring on the right destination and
embracing the journey but remember to
look back on the journey in order to
move forward
you